si d'être avec nous qui avons rouge
avait une hésitation pardonnez-moi sur
l'intitulé de votre syndicat pardonnez
moi alors on tant que soignant vous avez
évidemment participer et suivi cette
forte journée de mobilisation
on sait que ça fait des mois et des mois
que vous vous mobilisez il y aura des
annonces demain il y en a déjà eu est ce
que vous y croyez encore que ce type de
rassemblement puisse infléchir la
position du ministre oui tout à fait si
les hôpitaux sont revenus sur le devant
de la scène c'est parce que la
population a soutenu fortement les
soignants et a souhaité que l'hôpital
puisse répondre aux besoins de santé de
la population
parce que ça fait des années que l'on
ferme des lits que l'on supprime des
postes
donc aujourd'hui a eu bien sûr la
manifestation à paris des parisiens mais
surtout il ya eu presque un millier et
de rassemblements dans toute la france
elle même dans les petits départements
ruraux
vous aviez six ou sept villes qui
étaient mobilisés
donc voilà les gens ont compris que lors
de la crise qu vide on n'avait que cinq
mille hydre animations en france
l'allemagne on a les 25000 5 fois plus
du coup on a eu quatre fois plus de
morts que l'allemagne
donc chacun bien compris qu'il fallait
avoir un nombre suffisant de deux lits
pour répondre aux besoins de la
population
et là on voit bien qu'il ya un fort
soutien
les gens après les applaudissements aux
fenêtres sont aujourd'hui dans la rue à
nos côtés on voit bien dans tous les
cortèges dans toute la france qui avait
autant d'usagés que de deux blouses
blanches aux dents dans ces
rassemblements et ça fait chaud au coeur
parce que chacun a compris le problème
de la crise de l'hôpital
les citoyens français compris ça on n'en
doutait pas vraiment mais la question
c'est est ce que le ministre lui at il
entendu
non pas du tout c'est d'ailleurs très
très inquiétant parce que nous ce que
l'on constate sur le terrain c
que depuis le déconfinement on continue
à fermer des lits il ya le compris au
niveau saint bonnet que au niveau du chu
de strasbourg il ya quatorze lits de
réanimation qui ont été supprimés alors
qu'on en manquait tellement dans le
grand test et ils vous avez dans toute
la france
beaucoup d'hôpitaux ou en les directions
profite de cette phase pour ne pas
rouvrir les lits qui avait été fermée
pendant la phase que vides nous
concentrer les moyens sur les salles où
on s'occuper des patients que vides en
fermant les autres salles d'intervention
programmés et il est donc c'est un vrai
vrai problème parce que il ya eu le pic
de mortalité liée aux qu'ovide mais là
le risque clair c'est par rapport aux
gens qui ont des pathologies chroniques
ou qu'ils avaient des interventions
programmées mais non urgentes
donc tous ses passions que l'on a pas
suivi au mois de mars avril mai
ça on pensait les prendre en surplus en
juillet août
or on nous ferme des lits et donc nous
sommes obligés de décommander des
patients qui étaient prévus sur juillet
août alors que le il faudrait qu'on
puisse prendre ce qui avait été
décommandé pendant la phase qu'ovide
donc il ya un vrai décalage entre les
besoins de santé de la population et une
administration un peu folle nous oblige
à faire en enfermant des délices qui est
totalement incompréhensible rapidement 6
milliards d'euros quand même pour
revaloriser vos salaires jamais un
effort aussi grand n'avait été fait
c'est vraiment pas suffisant on vous
admettez quand même qu qu' il ya eu
voilà des concessions de la part du
gouvernement alors 6 milliards d'euros
pour 1,2 million de fonctionnaires à
l'hôpital et 500 mille salariés de la
santé dans le privé donc 6 milliards
pour un million sept
je vous donnerai l'exemple de air france
ou de renault qui ont eu 5 et 7
milliards pour 45 et 48 mille agents
donc on voit bien le décalage il faut
bien comprendre que quand même depuis 10
ans les gouvernements successifs ont
retiré 11,3 milliards au budget de la
santé qui ont fait 84 dont +10 % de
notre budget a été amputé ces dernières
années donc 6 milliards c'est une goutte
d'eau par rapport à la dette accumulée
par les gouvernements successifs depuis
dix ans thierry amouroux et agnès buzyn
s'est longuement exprimé devant la
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui
la question des masses vous concerne
directement vous les soignants elle a
expliqué qu'en gros le gouvernement
n'était pas vraiment responsable et des
commandes que c'était des commandes sim
et de la gestion des stocks non puisque
c'est l agence de santé régional est ce
qu'elle nous a convaincu l'ex ministre
de la santé aujourd'hui sur la gestion
de la crise et notamment sur cette
question des masques qui vous concerne
pas du tout elle est totalement
responsable et coupable à la fois de ne
pas avoir tenu compte du rapport de 2018
qui indiquait qu'il manquait des masques
et qu'il fallait ont commandé et le fait
que ea nous écrit perdre deux mois
cruciaux où elle n'a rien fait et rien
commandé donc bon c'est sûr que vu le
poids de sa culpabilité et les milliers
de morts qu il y a eu qui aurait pu être
évitable et qui sont liées à cette
décision lorsqu'on a autant de morts sur
la conscience on n'est pas un parjure
près donc voila mais ce qui est
dramatique c'est que elle continue de
d'être complètement à côté de la plaque
enfin bon 2 guillaud oui on était en
avance sur ce qui était guy au niveau
international alors que l'om est dé
février 10 fr où il faut tester tester
tester que depuis 100 ans
on sait que lorsqu'il est une maladie
respiratoire et b il faut avoir des
masques qui avait un milliard cinq cent
mille le masque
au moment de l'achat ena et qu' il n'y
en avait plus que 200 millions
enfin à fin 2010 8 enfin bon on voit un
gâchis incroyable et une faute très
lourde à la fois de la ministre des
cabinets ministériels et des hauts
fonctionnaires et c'est pour ça que vous
avez les 63 plaintes qui sont en cours
des plaintes pénales et des planes
devant la haute cour de justice et
qu'ils auront à répondre de ce scandale
merci beaucoup thierry amouroux d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france